liebe leute wir schreiben den 26 8 ich
weiß es gerne ich heute ist auf jeden
fall ein
ich habe keine ahnung welcher tages ist
aber wir waren wir 17 uhr 35 wir sind
heute um 13 uhr aufgestanden haben
geplant wie wir jetzt weiter fahren nach
kopenhagen nach schweden so lange damit
gekämpft unterkunft zu finden es ist
einfach so schwer haben jetzt ein
landhaus buch bezieht doppelzimmer da
aber erst für morgen abend
heute nacht werden wir im auto schlafen
das wird auch mal abenteuer gefahren
jetzt gleich von hamburg los richtung
kopenhagen werden dann irgendwo recht in
kopenhagen im parkhaus parken dann
feiern gehen im auto schlafen
am nächsten tag dann können wir um 16
uhr einchecken im doppelzimmer gebucht
haben bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt
das ganze unterfangen gewinnt jetzt noch
mal ein abenteuer charakter dadurch dass
wir im auto schlafen werden und auch
sonst recht wenig ahnung haben auf jeden
fall was noch feststeht ist dass wir
eine sehr sehr lange brücke passieren
werden
auf der fahrt nach dänemark ich weiß
nicht mehr genau den namen dieses extrem
lang führt übers offene gewässer das
wird bestimmt richtig gutes zu blocken
ich hoffe es noch nicht dunkel wieder im
kommen jetzt genug geredet leute und bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass da noch einiges
passieren wird das zuviel ob ich mich
freue
aber jetzt kommen lasst uns packen
welcher tag ist heute eigentlich der 26
wir können jetzt loslegen allerdings war
vorher eine kleinigkeit essen am
liebsten ein döner ehrlich gesagt
die
zusammen essen ist verdaut und wir haben
bereits eine stunde auf dem weg nach
kopenhagen zurück gelegt ist jetzt 20 19
die prognostizierte ankunftszeit ist 23
über 46 was er gar nicht gesehen habt
das war ein dünner
davon habe ich vor ort der würde wieso
gemacht dass der dönermann dönerfleisch
salat und pommes in eine schüssel
schmeißt dann alles berührt noch
bisschen soße obendrüber sour cream oder
was auch immer das ist
und dann wird es dann zu einer schüssel
zu bieten so eine auflaufform und das
ist extrem kein land auch nur 420 kostet
das sind die vorteile einer großstadt
da wo ich herkomme werde es
wahrscheinlich ein gericht für acht euro
gewesen
aber hey so hammer uns jetzt schön ein
gegönnt wollte eigentlich ehrlich auch
immer was einkaufen bevor wir nach denen
mal gehen wird ein bisschen getränke
bisschen was zu essen weil wir im auto
können
mal schauen vielleicht auch in kiel kiel
ist recht groß über 100.000 einwohner
da dürfte es eventuell zu geben der ein
bisschen salz vor offen hat
wir sind jetzt beim edeka belassen in
flensburg und kauft noch eine
kleinigkeit ein
so essen geholt jetzt tanken wir noch
kurz denn der sprit ist in dänemark
deutlich teurer
es geht voran wir sind gleich in new
york und nach newark kommt eine extrem
lange brücke über das offene wasser wie
ihr seht ihr am maßstab des extrem lang
also diesen 15 kilometer über so leute
wie sie nach der brücke jetzt hier wir
sind auf dem wasser da vorne sind
einfach zwei gigantische brückenträger
unter dem jetzt durch verlässt die
richtig krass alter muss noch krasser
seine taxe darüber völkerrechts nämlich
einfach mehr da unten sieht man noch ein
schiff brücke passiert bezahlt noch ein
stückchen gefahren und es ist null uhr
37 06 50 komplett in kopenhagen an
das sind 25 kilometer und ich bin halb
wie ein motto
die
so leute angekommen in kopenhagen sehr
schön
wir packen unser auto jetzt hier und
direkt die straße runter da vorne ist
wohl die innenstadt
also wir hoffen einfach als wir da rein
laufen wie eine möglichkeit finden wir
ein bisschen feiern zu gehen dann können
wir zwei stunden im auto irgendwo anders
hin